ein brisantes foto besudelt den
britischen thron nur ein paar tage nach
der verhaftung von maxwell am donnerstag
taucht jetzt ein foto auf dass die apps
die ihnen vertraute an der seite von
schauspieler kevin spacey zeigt und das
auf einem thron der queen
damit drückt erneut prinz andrew in den
fokus des apps dienst kann da ist den
die angebliche komplizen des us
sexualstraftäters jeffrey epstein im
britischen königshaus ein und aus
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
auge heft von bild stressor auge ganz
kurz mal warum ist dieses foto so
brisant und auch ein stück weit
ungeheuerlich brisant ist es weil es
zeigt dass die vertraute von jeffrey
epstein es in den buckingham-palast
geschafft hat dass fotos 2002
anscheinend entstanden das ist zur
hochphase dieses angeblichen
prostitutionsring der von jeff epstein
aufgebaut worden sein soll und dass
diese frau auf dem thron der queen setzt
und daneben setzt der gefallene
hollywood schauspieler kevin spacey der
nun auch kein unbeschriebenes blatt mehr
ist die beiden auf dem thron der der
königlichen macht das ist also eine
skandalöse unglaublich und das sieht du
sprichst es als skandalös stellt sich
die frage hat sich jemand aus dem
buckingham palace schon dazu geäußert
nein im moment noch nicht sind wir
natürlich auch alle ganz gespannt ob
dann noch mal was kommt das problem für
den buckingham palast ist dass man nicht
weiß wo die dieses futter an die
öffentlichkeit geraten ist und dem
palast ist eigentlich auch ein bisschen
die handhabe dieser ganze sache
entglitten sie sind nicht mehr herr der
lage dadurch auch das geschirr maxwell
jetzt auch gefasst worden ist
wir haben prinz andrew gerade
angesprochen warum ist dieses foto auch
für ihn so besonders was macht das ganz
gefährlich wie das gefährliche ist dass
prinz andrew wohl derjenige war der
diese tour damals ermöglicht hat es ist
nicht ungewöhnlich dass prominente gäste
in den buckingham-palast kommen aber
dass die dann hofft dem thron der queen
sitzen und da fotografiert werden und
dass das dann in die öffentlichkeit
kommen das zeigt dass prinz andrew
anscheinend mit der rolle der queen oder
der monarchie sehr lax umgegangen ist
also das beschädigt sein ruf also noch
mal sehr und es zeigt nochmal wo der nie
einen hehl daraus gemacht
das geschehe maxwell kennt aber es zeigt
wie eng die doch waren und das rückt den
halt natürlich auch zu denen also
vorwurf in diesen zweifelhaften kreis
von jackson doch intensiver in
verwickelt gewesen zu sein als er es
sagt wirtschaftsexperte hauke herr wir
freuen uns dass du uns bei diesem fall
weitere einschätzungen geben konntest
wir kommen gleich nochmal zu dir denn
wir machen mit einem anderen fall weiter
der rosenkrieg zwischen johnny depp und
seiner frau erstreckt sich nun schon
seit einigen jahren nun erreicht das
ganze einen neuen höhepunkt der grund
ein heimlich gefilmtes video
schauspieler johnny depp entdeckt dass
seine damalige frau amber hört einen
streit heimlich gefilmt hat der greift
sich eine weinflasche dann ist alles
nach einem kampf dieses schockierende
video material über johnny depp wurde am
dienstag vor einem gericht in london
gezeigt dass heimlich gefilmte videos
soll beweisen wie gewalttätig tab
gegenüber frauen sein kann
in dem gerichtsverfahren geht es genau
darum
der schauspieler wirft der britischen
zeitung 'the sun' verleugnung vor weil
diese berichtet hat dass sap seine frau
geschlagen und auch misshandelt habe in
dem artikel wird depp frauenschläger
genannt beide parteien erschienen vor
gericht als weiterer vorläufiger
höhepunkt im rosenkrieg der nach der
trennung der beiden vor vier jahren
begann in dem video das vor einigen
jahren in der küche von den beiden
entstand sieht man wie depp
offensichtlich im angetrunkenen zustand
auf möbel eintritt und die türen von
küchenschränken zu knallt was ist los
amber versucht beruhigend auf ihn
einzureden
was ist los
heute morgen ist nichts passiert weißt
du das okay wir sehen hier das video
vielleicht kannst du uns einordnen was
da zu sehen ist ist ja ein bisschen
verpixelt warum die aufnahme die
aufnahme ist jetzt in dem
gerichtsprozess der gestern gestartet
ist sondern mit johnny depp ist jetzt
noch mal als beweismaterial gezeigt
worden und soll die aggressive ist auch
sagen stimmung oder die aggressive
persönlichkeit von johnny depp zeigen
beweisen dass videos 2016 schon mal an
die öffentlichkeit gekommen und damals
wusste man aber nie so ganz genau ist
das jetzt echt weil wie du es ja gesagt
dass man erkennt nicht genau ist ist
johnny depp ist die danach aus aber
jetzt wissen wir ja es ist ein video auf
dem johnny depp von amber heard zu sehen
sind das teil dieses gerichtsverfahren
sondern kann man jetzt schon nachdem man
das video gesehen hat davon ausgeben das
ja offensichtlich jemand da im recht
oder unrecht ist also das ist schwer zu
sagen
johnny depp ist mit seinen anwälten auch
nicht um clever gewesen die haben
kürzlich auch ein foto veröffentlicht wo
johnny depp verletzt auf einer trage
liegt angeblich verletzter und amber
heard das ist alles teil dieser
auseinandersetzung zwischen den beiden
die eigentlich schon lange vorbei war
die aber jetzt wieder hochkommt und das
video wird natürlich benutzt
es ist ohne die einbindung von johnny
depp aufgenommen worden damals das macht
es etwas besonderes da man es nicht
benutzen aber es bleibt natürlich haften
und setzt ein image von johnny depp in
der öffentlichkeit das ist ein thema was
glaubst du denn was das ganze für folgen
haben kann einerseits wie johnny depp
aber natürlich auch für die prozess für
den prozess lässt sich das moment noch
nicht absehen weil johnny depp gestern
auch ordentlich zurück gefeuert hat und
die anschuldigungen eigentlich an mba
hat an seine ex-frau zurückgegeben hat
und gesagt hat dass sie die aggressive
personen in dieser beziehung ist man
muss sagen die ehe ist wirklich nach
einem jahrzehnt beendet worden
das macht das ganze schon komisch und
sehr merkwürdig johnny depp hat
ziemliche rückendeckung von seinen
ehemaligen partnerin union rider und
auch weil es der paradis bekommen die
alle weile gesagt haben dass er keine
aggressive persönlichkeit ist das wird
der prozess vor drei wochen gehen das
wird noch sind erst am anfang also noch
lange hin und her gehen
fakt ist das ist jetzt zwischen den
beiden aber noch mal richtig schmutzig
wird und dass man da alle winkelzüge
ausnutzen wird
vielen dank für deine einschätzung in
diesen beiden fällen danke dir